hello everyone I'm really excited to be
here because the first international
conference talk that I ever gave was
actually right here on this stage I came
in 2016 for I think it was the very
first CSS company the past and what I
talked about was actually styling using
just CSS and HTML but now today we're
gonna bring CSS HTML in the little bit
of JavaScript together and see how we
could craft stateful styles with state
machines which Mike talked about at the
very beginning so basically the hello
world of any design system any component
library is of course your button so
imagine we have this button you get this
design you're happy it looks good but
there's many different variants like
Mike talked about that this button can
be in so we have to consider what
happens if you hover the button what
happens if the button is active and what
happens that the button is disabled so
you might be thinking we're done here
but we have to also think about the
application states that this button can
be into for example if we're fetching
data we might want to fade it out if
it's a success we might want to have it
be green and say hey we've got your data
or if it's an error you might want it to
be a different variants such as red but
looking at application behavior and
component Styles this way is very
limited because we also have to think
about how we transition between these
states to illustrate this problem let's
say we have this fetch button user
clicks it we're waiting for data and we
eventually get it that's great
but what happens if the data takes a
long time to load then maybe we want to
show a spinner and eventually we get our
data but if you're like me then you'll
get frustrated after a while and start
clicking this button a few times and
this is gonna make a lot of unnecessary
API requests until you finally get your
data but you're a developer and you're
smart you think you know what
I'm going to disable the button and that
way they could only click it once they
have to wait for the data and then it
comes back successfully but guess what
I'm a developer too I know chrome dev
tools so I could just go in under Sabol
that button and make as many requests as
I want so I ran into this problem a lot
of times and I wasn't always good at
JavaScript which is why at the very
beginning I decided to see how much I
could do with just HTML and CSS this was
one of the very first code pens that I
made using hover States to just go
between the days and recreate this
dribble by 2bic studio as well as this
one now to do to do complex animations
like this you sort of have to use a few
hacks if you're not going to use
JavaScript and so that's exactly what I
did just like was talked about in the
very first talk I used check boxes
because check boxes can represent States
and radio buttons as well so what I did
here was if you have a checkbox and it
sort of lives outside the app you could
use the squiggly selector a tilde
selector which is more formally known as
the adjutant sibling selector but I mean
no one's gonna remember that and you
could apply a label inside the app that
labels are great because they magically
map the the check box over to the label
in your app so when you click the label
it doesn't matter where it is it will
check that checkbox and so what happens
is when you click that label which could
be a button or anything else then that
check box is going to be checked you
could use the squiggly selector and
select that box and make it change
styles and you could also do this with
more than one check box which gives you
sort of that dynamic behavior and
dynamic styling now like I mentioned you
could do this with both check boxes and
radios with one distinction with check
boxes you could have zero or more check
boxes checked but while I found myself
using more and more for radio buttons
because it enforced the idea that you
could have only one of them checked at a
time so I was playing around with this
and I was playing around with crazier
things like this CSS only dog animation
that I
showed at the very first CSS company the
pest that I was at and I decided to go
with my friends sha and we do this
weekly livestream called the key framers
in which we bring imaginative user
interfaces to like using HTML CSS and a
little bit of JavaScript so what we do
is we take these really complex
animations from Tribble and we try to
recreate them live on the air in under
two hours but what we found ourselves
seeing more and more is that a lot of
these animations are States based and
not just two states so we can't use a
checkbox but three states where you
click and you know you might go back or
you might have this play button and then
you go to something else so that's more
easily illustrated here because we have
this plateless state at the top which
shows what state our app is in and you
could scroll through these albums and
this is another recreation of a dribble
and so you could drag back and forth and
you could see that the state of our
entire application changes as the user
interacts with this application so you
could see those moving side to side so
this sort of illustrates the problem
that we have with our currents design
systems in the current way that we
develop is that a designer might present
you a very high fidelity mock-up or you
know just like a simple prototype but
that mock-up represents only one of
potentially many if not hundreds
thousands of possible states that your
app of your components can be in and so
the problem I'm sorry the problem is
that this Ireson cycle is a bit slow
because not only does a designer have to
make all of those changes in all of
those different screens but if the logic
changes of the design changes you have
to go through all of those possible
changes or all those possible screens
and apply those changes so what what we
do currently today and I'm sure most of
you are guilty of this I know I was
guilty of the
for the longest time is we apply classes
we're like okay if this button is in the
loading state then we have a class of
loading of course so we could do the
same with success but the problem with
classes we can't enforce that we only
have one possible value so we might have
a button that shows loading and success
and some of you might think like I'm I'm
smart enough not to do this I have class
list I could remove the loading class
and then at the success class by this
many of you know this does happen in the
real world and this is something that we
wants to avoid so is there a better way
that we could model the state for our
dynamic UI's and have it in a way that
we could visualize it and easily see all
these possible states and be able to
know how states change from one state to
another in our app and can we do it in a
more formal way that designers and
developers can understand equally so I
looked at a lot of different prototyping
apps like origami design envision app
which you define each of the different
states in it smoothly transitions
between each of them prototype does the
same thing where it's sort of like magic
move for designers because you could
define shapes and it will magically
transform then scale them translate them
into the shape that they're supposed to
be and you could add triggers and then
there's more formal user flow tools such
as overflowed IO in which you could
design each of these screens and add
these custom triggers so what I realized
was common between all of these tools
and more is that user flows are these
transitions between these user interface
States and these transitions could be
caused based on either user events or
other external events such as a timer an
API requests coming in etc and so this
brings me to the topic of finite state
machines and state charts which I mean
if you know me long enough you know that
this is what I talked about you could
type state machine on Twitter and I will
find you and I will respond to you it's
just my thing one of my favorite
definitions of the states is
actually in the Aria guidelines in the
w3.org website where a States is a
dynamic property that expresses the
characteristics of an object in a
certain point of time so this point of
time can be in response to a user action
or other automated processes or external
events that come in and so this is a
distinction between properties such as
like an anchor might have an H ref tag
or an href attribute or a button can
have a variant where you know that
that's not going to change but state is
different state describes at one point
in time this represents my component and
that could change at any time and area
also has all of these builds and
attributes for states that they describe
a stateful attributes which describe you
know certain finite states of components
such as invalid valid disabled currents
and yeah so finite state machines are
pretty much the same concept where it
has five parts I'm gonna review finite
state machines real briefly there's a
ton of resources on this though but the
finite state machine is one that has an
initial state it has a finite number of
states which means we could only be in
one of those states at a time it has a
finite number of vents and these are the
signals that cause transitions between
those states it has a mapping of
transitions that go between those states
so for example for an idle and the user
makes a fetch request by pressing a
button now we're in the pending States
and it also has a finite number of final
states which represent the app being
done there being no more left to do so
the beauty of these finite state
machines is number one they could be
visualized such as this state diagram
and number two they outline just all the
possible transitions and what's not
possible as well so if we do a search
action on the searching state we realize
that there is no transition outgoing
from the searching State so that search
should have no effect and this is
exactly what we wants to occur so that
the user isn't
keep making all of these different API
requests so to do this in CSS in HTML
and to do it in a scalable way I
employed the use of data attributes so
whereas we can't use Aria attributes for
everything we could use data attributes
to describe a more colorful and more
varied way of describing all of the
possible states of our application or of
the individual components as well the
other attributes are something that are
very underused but this goes back to the
beginning of HTML and I highly encourage
you to use it because they end up being
a lot simpler than class names to use so
for example we could have a data state
equals loading and we could target that
using an attribute selector in CSS data
state equals loading and so in
JavaScript it actually makes it really
easy to to change the the data attribute
of whatever you're working with so we
could have a data state and we could say
you know it's loading your success and
then we could change that or we could
delete it completely and then it's gone
and so changing it is just setting that
attribute and deleting it is just
deleting so there's no weird api's like
classless dot add class list that has
class lists that remove that you have to
worry about it's just JavaScript so
these data attributes represents each
one of these finite States in your
components or your application for
example this button we could have data
state of idle which means nothing
happened yet
we could have loading we could have a
success and we could have a failure so
you could also imagine that you you can
name these states whatever you want and
that's the beauty of these data
attributes so how do we implement data
attributes with these finite States
traditionally finite state machines
especially in other languages can be
done using switch case statements where
you would first figure out what state
you're in and you would switch on that
so for example for in the searching
state we go to the key statement for
search
and then we switch on what events
occurred so if you're used to Redux on
them getting into JavaScript a little
bit here by Redux or ng rx or any of
those reducers then typically you would
do action first but now we're doing it
the other way around we're looking at
what state were on first and then we're
going to the event I call it embeds
instead of action because that's a more
accurate term but we check what events
just happened and what state we should
go to next based on that event such as
success and of course if that is not
handled by the switch case statement
then you just default to the same state
now personally I find switch case
statements a little bit verbose so I
like to do object mapping instead and so
this is just you it looks like a big
JSON object and it's essentially the
same idea where you have a state such as
searching you look at the on property to
see which events just occurred and if
there's a mapping between the events and
the next state that should happen and if
there isn't you just default to the
current state so I also wrote a library
for this called XE which you do not have
to use it doesn't apply directly to what
I'm talking about because you could do
this today without any JavaScript
library but I just felt like mentioning
it because it does have a lot of these
things built in to use x8 you would just
have a machine function which takes in
that object configuration and it gives
you a few nice things such as automatic
transitions so you don't need to code
that transition function yourself and
you could say if I'm in the idle State
and these search events happens then we
should go to the searching State that's
actually wrong I'll correct that but
yeah so here's an example over here have
you ever wondered how how they implement
sort of a drag-and-drop type of thing I
mean it looks pretty simple but then you
get around to trying to implement it and
seeing okay which event listeners do I
need to listen to what do I have to do
when do I stop listening to these event
listener
and it just gets really confusing so you
probably reach for a library but it's
actually a lot simpler than it seems if
you think about drag-and-drop as two
states either idle or dragging anything
about four properties the X and y which
represents the position of the object
and the dxdy which represents how far
you move the object then it becomes
pretty easy to visualize this as two
states idle and then when you pick
something up like this that's like
you're dragging state's own I'm changing
the dxdy properties and then I would
move it somewhere and then once I stop
now I'm in the idle State again
and so we could visualize this here once
I start dragging you see those dxdy
properties moving and then I drop it and
then now I change those to x and y and
then I could do it again and so you can
see it's very easy to visualize these
two states within the context of your
application in your animations and this
on this playing by the way using those
data attributes as well so we could also
if you want to do more advanced
animations based on what state you're on
and what state you came from because the
different actions that could happen
depend on which state that you may have
come from and so that's why using a data
pre state attribute stands for previous
state can be useful as well because you
know we could have two different things
for example if we're coming to a loading
state from an idle state that might do
one thing but if we're coming from an
error state then maybe we want to show
an error gone animation and then we're
back to loading and then so in our same
function where we apply those data
attributes we would just set the
previous state to whatever the state was
before and we could target those right
in our CSS just by combining those
selectors like so and so this if it ever
loads is an example of that so we have
different behaviors based on whether
going up for example and then we have a
difference animation over here and then
going down it does something different
so we do want to keep track of which
state that we came from and so again
this is using data attributes to change
which state were in so so as I started
playing around more with this idea of
using finite state machines for
animations I saw more and more complex
animations on Tribble that I really want
to recreate such as this one by Cal
shear which lets you extend your weekend
which I really hope I was I want to do
this weekend
so I broke this animation down and I
start to see all of the different states
of it so at the beginning when the user
starts dragging their mouse then we
start searching or sorry we start
selecting each of the days and then once
the user let's go now we're in the
selected state so now a mouse movement
is going to mean something different
because then we're in the dragging state
and we could move those states around
and then we're in the disposed dates so
once we start grabbing now the mouse
movement means something different it
means we're extending a day so the exact
same events can mean something different
depending on what state you're on and I
think that that's a really important
point so just to show you over here if I
start dragging and selecting remember
mouse movement means one thing so I
could start dragging over here and if I
don't go to the trash can then it just
goes back there and back to that state
and so I could drag it all the way here
disposes and then now I'm in the
grabbing state which means that if I
move my mouse and I start dragging
outside it's not gonna have that initial
behavior of showing the selection
rectangle because I'm not in that state
where that behavior is defined so that's
an important point when dealing with
application state is not just mapping an
event to an action or to side effects
but instead mapping it to what state
you're in
and what events just have
mapping those two together so using the
state machine which I created using x8
but of course you don't need to you
could also automatically generate
visualizations such as this which
explained the whole process of the logic
of you know how the app is supposed to
behave once you're dragging and dropping
certain things so does this scale that's
a big problem which which we have to
talk about because of course once you
have so many different combinations like
Mike was talking about then we could
have an exponentially large number of
states and we sort of need to manage
that thankfully a solution in 1987 by a
computer scientist by the name of David
Harrell sort of solved that for us it
says 1997 there but it was actually a
decade earlier so these are really
really old ideas state charts extend the
idea of state machines by adding things
such as actions whether you're entering
state exiting a state or performing a
transition between states it has guards
so you can make sure that transitions
only occur when a condition based on the
state is met there's also the idea of
hierarchy so you could have nested
states you can think of those as sub
routes or if you're in one state and you
could be in a sub state of that state
also orthogonality which represents two
different ideas of states which don't
really have too much to do to each with
each other but you want to represent
them both equally
and the idea of history States as well
so hierarchical states can really help
simplify how we combine States and make
the logic easier so we see in the
success and failure state the search
events can occur from both of them so
instead we could group those two
together and make it so that whether
we're in the success or failure state
that search events can take us back to
the searching State so in X state that's
done just by nesting those states within
the search State over there and then we
could see that when we perform the
search event on any of those states then
we go back to the searching State so it
really simplifies the design of these of
the logic
now to represent these nested states and
hierarchical states in CSS we have to
get a little bit into the weeds of data
attribute selectors so of course we have
the existence selector which just checks
if it exists we have the data attribute
selector of if it's exactly equal to if
it contains anywhere at all if it starts
with something such as idle if it
contains or if it ends with something
such as error or this is the one we want
if our data state or our data attribute
contains the string passed in such as
idle error but that string is basically
a word that's separated by whitespace
and this makes it acts just like a class
now this isn't the same as saying that
we're in two states at the same time
we're really in this idle dot error
state but we want that idle just to let
CSS know that we are in that parent
state and so we could use data
attributes as like even further like
data show and data hide and use that to
show which elements are active based on
which state we're on and so that's just
with a little bit of JavaScript you
don't need to read this code right now
but just know that by by just figuring
out what state were in we could show
elements based on what state we're on
and so you could play around with the
idea you don't have to use data show
where dala hide you could just use
whatever you want to use but the idea is
that you're not directly toggling
classes are talking attributes on each
of these states so for the final example
here's this password form and you can
see that there's this idol and Idol dot
normal sub state that we're in because
if I enter a password incorrectly and it
validates now we go to isle dot error
and eventually it goes back to idle dot
normal because we want those two states
to be similar but also we want them to
be distinct enough so that we could
group its similar characteristics and
its unique characteristics such as
showing the red outline when when the
password is incorrect then we eventually
have a success date as well
so the main idea that I want to bring
home to you is that you should think in
states and events and not just events
and the reason for doing this is because
once you define your application in your
components as a finite state machine or
a state chart and you model it in a very
explicit way you could do some really
cool things such as visualize these and
so just to show you that animation I
just showed you can be visualized right
over here so I copied and pasted of the
machine used to define and we could see
that we're in the Isle States but we're
also in the normal state as well and so
when we change now we go to the
validating state in if it's an error
then it's invalid and then we go back to
the normal States just like that
now so there's a lot of powerful
applications of this such as analysis
automatic testing and other things that
I talked about but there's also other
tools that could do this for you sketch
systems is a very useful tool for
prototyping your applications and your
designs using these AI same ideas of
finite state machines and state charts
because you could write it in this
pseudo syntax and be able to play around
with it in a little prototype editor at
the bottom so I highly encourage you to
check that out there's a lot of
advantages to using state charts NASA
use them that their selves with the Mars
rover which I mean honestly if you have
one shot at going to production with a
multi hundred billion dollar thing you
don't want to [ __ ] it up
so I mean imagine doing this in
JavaScript it would it would go nowhere
so there's a lot of advantages to this
they had visualized modeling precise
diagrams they were able to use those
state charts to generate code
automatically and also to make sure that
every single possible thing that could
happen to this Mars rover was tested and
was covered and also when requirements
changed they didn't have to go into code
to figure out what needs to change but
instead they could just go to the
diagram and see okay this is now this so
now we have to have an arrow
here and this goes here and so it's a
lot easier to to deal with these
automatic late-breaking changes with
visual diagrams instead of code now of
course there are disadvantages because
as you could tell there is a huge
learning curve and modeling these day
charts requires planning ahead you can't
just put your head down in code you need
to actually stop and plan it and draw
those boxes and draw those arrows and
give it to your developers and designers
and say is this a correct behavior in
our application and of course you can't
just use finite state machines for
everything but they could be a very good
abstraction for the overall logic of
your applications there are also
complexity trade-offs where you might
say I don't need state charts because my
application is so simple and that's when
you might use finite state machines
whereas normal code which I call
bottom-up code because we're putting
everything in the event listeners
instead of instead of structuring it in
a nice modeled way it increases linearly
but as we saw finite state machines can
increase exponentially state charts
however might seem more complex at first
but they manage complexity at scale and
this is why I love using them because no
trivial app ever stays trivial once more
features come in it becomes so much more
complex and you want a good way to
manage that complexity there's a lot of
resources online for learning about
state machines and state charts which I
encourage you to check out there's a
community on spectrum Piazza de chartes
and there's the world of state charts
which just explains in the very easy to
read way how to get started with stage
arts and what kinds of problems they
solve
so in general I want to make your code
do more than just applying the
application logic I want you to be able
to visualize automatically test analyze
simulate your applications in your
components and be able to visualize all
the possible states and transitions
between your components and applications
thank you very much CSS contest
[Applause]